hello I'm Chris and I'm Emily and I'm here to
see if I can become best friends with anyone
on the street we'll only have five minutes
to get to know each other using questions
from this deck of cars before we go head
to head in a trivia challenge I'm doing
this because the pandemic has just eliminated
my social abilities and we need to rebuild I
know I could anyone like I could move
to anyone and become besties all right
so I have about five minutes to find my new
best friend on the street let's go foreign
no okay excuse me
sorry to bother you I'm just looking
for someone who's going to take five
minutes to try and become best
friends with me on the street
okay I understand I appreciate it though thank you
you don't have five minutes to try and become best
friends with me on the spot okay I appreciate
that I'll take that do you have five minutes to
try and become best friends with me right now
sure I've only got a few minutes oh yes okay
excuse me do you want to be
best friends sure okay cool
I did it I'm Emily oh my God wait I think
where'd you get it the Dr does Dominican
Republic I'm Dominican shut up oh my God I know we
are instantly best friends Arthur we have about 30
questions in only five minutes mathematically
it's gonna be a little tight but we need to
get to know each other okay all right ready what
is your favorite movie everything everywhere all
at once mine is part and Prejudice what is your
middle name Adams Adams Russell Adams Russell that
should be easy to remember right we'll see we're
killing we're moving here we go do you have any
siblings in what are their names Karen Mark Sandy
Karen Mark Sandy Kirsten younger sister Kirsten
what is your most impressive skill aerial arts I
can sing a word okay Karen what were your name I
won't let myself forget that how are we doing on
time I feel like I'm going too slow I'm going to
run out of time what is your most annoying habit
I don't know this question is kind of weird next
what is your middle name Rose Carmen okay oh my
God I'm not moving fast enough uh what is your
favorite band artist slash musician I'll
go Elvis for just a favorite uh I love it
let's double up let's double up this isn't
cheating we're just already excuse me very
aligned what is your biggest goal in life to
win an Oscar wait minus win an Academy Award
hey see you there see you there best friend
okay what do you do to get rid of stress sex
it's a good answer that's a great answer
my family watching maybe I agree uh
uh the PG answer is watch TV January 20th okay
so your birthday's coming generation mine is
April 7th April 7th yeah my most impressive
skill playing drums okay yeah there you go
okay what is your favorite oh I think I answered
everything what was your favorite movie proud
and Prejudice Pride and Prejudice uh everything
everywhere all at once yes best friends all right
I think we have a few more here um we barely got
to know each other I have uh I trust that we were
just like in sync zoning it yeah it doesn't matter
irrelevant we're gonna nail this okay let's do it
wasn't
uh if you know you know do you know are
you guessing no I know I also know Brown
hey good job having brown eyes brown eyes uh
uh January 5th wow April 7 and I'm an
Aries very interesting yeah two to two
she puts up her fists I don't know
I'm hearing a lot of excuse excuses
drums I'm a drummer technically oh so you don't
think drums are interesting okay aerial arts
aerial arts three to two no word at all
yeah oh I'm trying to think of what I said
what if I don't remember but I know I agreed
with Arthur whatever it was doesn't sound like
it's a point leaving New York yes an airplane
I don't know if I would count that one spiders
oh my God 100 confident in my bestie loser excuse
me excuse me uh this is as good as we're gonna
get three siblings two sisters one brother Karen
Mark Sandy I got two and points shaking their head
off camera I have a sister named Kirsten and
she only had to memorize one his middle name
that's what you want obviously I know middle
name's middle name my middle name is Russell
so close Andy so close Razor's Edge Carmen oh man
we're ahead by Five Points ten yeah yeah it's like
I think it's much closer it's much closer the
math is not math win or lose what we've built
is so much more important than this game I just
want to let that go on record so true oh dude
hold on a very long year 3 000. I did
the far future the year 2700. that is not
only 300 that's that's enough they ever
take 300 years the Golden Age of Hollywood
Golden Era pretty pretty broad pretty broad
yeah I mean yeah give or take 300 years yeah
that's fine that's golden age that's
nothing of the universe oh my God yeah
show us the shoe old man Reeboks dress shoes
adorable adorable oh oh I want
to know what's going on over
here because it's bordering
on uh suspicious my dog Bella
oh yeah my sister Kirsten with the heart wow
there's like so easy six four I'm guessing
somewhere around six foot four oh what an insane
question to get a spot on five three oh wow
I feel like I disappointed you in some
moments there though you could never
disappoint me that means right here you
can't lose if you've got a best friend
now we're not friends anymore thanks for
this video we will never be friends ever